ist mir gerade die idee gekommen dass
wir das so machen wenn ihr mehr bock hat
auf mehr solcher challenges dann
schreibt mir jetzt eure challenges in
die kommentare
das sollten minecraft zb du musst bis
morgen fünf leute in einer runde
survival camps töten oder hören was muss
irgendwie vor der kamera einen
runterholen genau schreibt schreibt
challenges und bestrafung in die
kommentare jetzt ein bisschen zu groß zu
grausam weiter ich habe jetzt schon
naja erfolgt schreibt in die kommentare
servus leute herzlich willkommen zu
einem minecraft kommentare heute geht es
um das thema das ich leider eine kleine
beschissene wette verloren habe und
jetzt was machen muss coco crafter
du musst jetzt hundefutter richtig hart
essen richtig harte sich lecker
vielleicht auch weil ich essen
vielleicht kaufe ich darf aber auf jeden
fall muss ich mir das einverleiben auf
irgendeine art und weise das wird
ziemlich heftig denke ich mir mal und er
hat mir gedacht dieses diese idee diese
das mandat das sie dass ich mir selbst
und allen stelle mit einem gewissen
wetteinsatz das sei ziemlich lustig
sowohl für mich als auch für euch und es
ist schon ziemlich gut angekommen und
deswegen ist mir gerade die idee
gekommen dass wir das so machen wenn ihr
mehr bock hat auf mehr solcher
challenges dann schreibt mir jetzt eure
challenges in die kommentare
das sollten minecraft zum beispiel du
musst bis morgen fünf leute in einer
runde survival games töten oder hören
was muss irgendwie ist aber der kamera
einen runterholen genau schreibt
schreibt challenges und bestrafung in
die kommentare jetzt und wenn ihr mehr
wenn ihr bock auf mehr von diesen
challenges habt von diesen wetten dann
lasten like da lassen wir das wissen und
wie gesagt challenges und bliebe strafen
in die kommentare
dann kann man vielleicht mehr von dieser
sorte manche kommentare schreiben ob
jetzt skl sebastian flüssiges also so
ekliges euch das hundefutter fressen
muss oder trocken
und er machte er dann mit face kann so
richtig ein
das heißt was ist mit face käm ich mache
von raab video daraus der
kickers-trainer genau was lecker du
machst du so ein teller und macht darauf
hier nicht los und ja ich mache ich mir
das möchte ich bin ganz schön rot
verlassen
genau das wird das wird ganz ganz schön
wenn die delikatessen müsse noch von den
guten wein begleitet werden das war
richtig lecker ist das wird auch so dass
ich freue mich auch schon darauf wieder
auf dem hause ich weiß gar nicht ob
vielleicht hungrig aber die nächsten
tage damit ich dieses ding haben wir
einen bekomme
keine ahnung ganz aber auch marc
bisschen deswegen keine ahnung bitte an
e mail kann max max nicht dessen es geht
mal nicht aber auf jeden fall
ich weiß noch nicht wann es wieder
hochkomme das würde ich auch gerne
mitteilen
ich denke dass es am montag kommt war
ich immer ich muss den schüssel als
macht kaufen
emma laden meine hände ging schon wieder
was los alter und dementsprechend kann
ich jetzt noch nicht morgen aufnehmen
und heute kommt die folge auch noch
nicht heute erzähle ich einfach ein
bisschen darüber wie leben ist seitdem
ich diese wette verloren habt und euch
einfach nur fragen ob ich das im
allgemeinen gefällt beziehungsweise ich
werde es nach der bestattung bestimmt
auch mal fragen und nicht vergessen
feucht ist oder trocken doch besser
er will sich der wirklich drücken
das würde es verdächtig kein hundefutter
essen was ich will auch gar nicht ran
stirbst alter nicht sterben ich hab das
alles schon gegoogelt hab schon
gegoogelt ob unterschiedlich ist und
also die meinung auch gut auf
gutefrage.net richtig kompetente
antworten dort alles zu 100 prozent
genau die haben aber auch alle dr.in
hunde kunde den sc in die kommentare
feuchtes trocken ist und noch die
anderen bestrafungen und challenges die
ja noch machen soll
und ich glaube das war es erstmal oder
wir können ein bisschen tanzen als
gewissen gerade erst bei vier minuten
ist das video doch ein bisschen länger
machen und wir haben noch ein bisschen
was zu sagen
januar falls sich das gefallen hat dann
wie gesagt schreibe es in die kommentare
ob ihr mehr davon wollte ganz wichtig
ist auch schreibt eure changes und die
bestrafung in die kommentare
damit wir da weit mehr vormachen kann
nach diesem kanal auf dem ihr gerade
seid und rocco costa was gibt's von
deiner da noch zu sagen
ergeben sich sehr guten appetit ja das
wird eine richtig schöne spezialität aus
dem hause ea wie gesagt
also ja das ist dir schmecken 8 ein
schönes video draus union habe ich
gesagt dass ich es filme habe ich gesagt
ich glaube nicht doch hast du nein
auf jeden fall wird ein richtig geiles
video und habe ich am alter dass muss
ich gleich mal checken
das muss ich gleich mal checken ob ich
gesagt habe dass ich das filme aber ein
bisschen reue ich nach soja alzheimer
ist jetzt schon bei esta bisschen habe
ich da hast du hast du die folge gesehen
habe ich das wirklich gesagt er ich
keine ahnung können wir danach nochmals
ja das ist weiter fördern schreibt sie
die kommentare feucht oder trocken und
da noch andere challenges jänner andere
chaseco freut sich und die krankhafte
bestimmt auch und ja max max der der
hund hatte letztlich so gefeiert
in seiner folge eine kleine rote reich
doch hundefutter trotzdem ich werde aber
nicht nur da so also ich mehr oder bloß
haut da ja leute dann wartet ab ich
denke in den nächsten zwei tagen wie
gesagt am montag wird dann das video
kommen falls ich gesagt habe
ansonsten werden wir auch aus dem staub
machen nein ich denke schon dass ich das
bringen werde
das ist eine ehrensache und ja wie
gesagt dann bleibt dran
der chronograph das jetzt schon gemietet
weil irgendwas passiert ist bei ihnen
wahrscheinlich wurde gerade erschossen
dinge dinge passieren
seine eltern damit wieder misshandelt
sowie sie mal halt passiert bei ihm
erging aber im haushalt krug oder
crafter dem 1 1 81 vor einlass
dann macht's gut ihr sprecher
das wird so grausam zu grausam weiter
ich habe jetzt schon wussten naja oder